game you got a sellout alert on that
stay trashy tour look out we're adding
shows we're selling out shows we're
adding City bring the squad it's a good
time Gang mix of stand-up comedy and of
course you play the language with the
crowd come out and see us yeah the big
man ain't lying starting in March we're
going to be in Baltimore Virginia Beach
Richmond Oklahoma City Dallas Texas
Houston Texas all right Austin Texas
sold out second show out and get those
tickets get those ticks then in April
New Haven Connecticut Burlington Vermont
then in May we're going to Tampa Florida
that sold out we added another one let's
go now we're going to Dania Beach
Florida then we're going to Raleigh
North Carolina then in may we had a
Louisville Kentucky get those tickets
and then in June we have Cleveland and
Columbus guys tickets are moving don't
snooze on it let's party we'll see you
there see you there welcome to another
exciting edition of are you garbage the
show where you find out if your favorite
comedians are classy individuals or
absolute trash now you here are your
hosts Kevin Ryan and H Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is are you garbage oh yeah it's that
little show we sit down with your
favorite comedians and we find out
they're going to be classy yeah it's
just a big old piece of trash I'm your
host stage Foley coming at you on a
beautiful day we're down here at
antuti's basement she keeps talking
about this money she's got coming in
okay she doesn't know what she wants to
do she wants to put some on the street
she wants to get in the horse racing the
dog track she's not really sure big
meeting with her lawyer today great he's
in prison
he's in prison yeah I just been doing
the fist pump through the glass
so we'll see how it all shakes out great
Mike co-host is coming at you from right
next to me he is the CEO of Ru garbage
he's an international businessman he's
wearing an orange shirt for some reason
give it up for KJ Kevin James right
you're wearing a purple shirt for some
reason we're dressing too much uh what's
up everybody thanks for tuning in as
always please make sure you rate you
subscribe on iTunes full video available
on YouTube as you know those numbers are
and then obviously the greatest gosh
darn website of all time
www.patreon.com baby sign up over there
get I think it's maybe 2.5 bajillion
hours of content available over there on
patreon so sign up gang a lot going on
love that money having a nice quick
shout out to our producer Jesus
how about a nice quick shout out to our
producer extraordinaire the magic man
makes us all look good works the ones
Works tattoos crosses the t's and dots
the eyes give it up for T-Bone McMuffin
Toby McMullen everybody what's up dudes
what's up dude great day beautiful
sunshine and we got a great guest but
let me tell you something you walk into
a bar you see some cash on one of the
bar games you walk away if this Rod's on
the sticks for sure the hustler baby
hustler in the flesh you got Paul Newman
in here
getting the long hair ain't lying
because we couldn't be more excited to
have our incredibly and I mean
incredibly special guest back with us
again today she's family at this point
yeah she's on tour right now you know
her you love her she has a brand new
special available over there on her
website that you gotta check out in
title dazzler and it'll be on YouTube
March 9th do us a favor give it up for
Kelsey cook everybody let's go let's go
thank you for coming this is great oh my
God brought on the sticks is like maybe
my favorite introduction
yeah that's pretty good honestly yeah
let's get the shirts let's get the merch
going on the sticks oh that makes me
feel so much cooler than I am I like
that it is cool I really like that I'm
wearing all leather smoking yeah
sunglasses at night like the black widow
yeah by the way real quick how do I turn
the headphones down a little bit I do
that for you right here oh beautiful
coming in hot I remember seeing your
ankles before Toby yeah show a little
skin yeah I don't know if I like it
that's a nice ankle that's a family
program you put those away also change
my shirt to Green in post I'm a little
self-conscious now maybe black just put
me in a black tea
okay take it easy pumpkin buddy
congratulations on the special thank you
very excited to tour you're killing it
you're all over the place we love it
thank you for coming you said before we
started you got a little Paparazzi
stalking you well and I have to preface
this it is not a me thing at there there
should not be Paparazzi for me under any
circumstances
[Laughter]
I'm with my family
I was just I was at the helium in Philly
and the club manager told me as we
pulled up he's like just so you know on
Saturdays here at the club there are a
couple Paparazzi that show up to get
pictures of comics to try and sell the
Getty Images
he's got a day job for sure that guy
that guy ain't living off Philly
paparazzi that's a Chipotle during the
day yeah there's definitely a cold pizza
sitting on that front seat that was
supposed to be delivered an hour ago
also we were there nobody took pictures
of us no Paparazzi showed up see and I
just my mom was there I'm like who is
buying this like the headline being like
comic clocks in like nobody
Kelsey cook confused
doing the things she does every weekend
and uh so they took these pictures of me
I was so startled I've never had this
happen and uh I walked in are they out
there with the flashes and all that
stuff I mean like they really let's see
over here over here they like got in my
face it was it was a whole Ambush
feeling and then I walked into the shows
I looked online the next day and I have
to I wonder if we can like pull it up
for you guys to see what is it okay so
do um Kelsey cook
um Philly maybe yeah Kelsey Kelsey cook
spits on photographer
if you do or like comedian Kelsey cook
in Philly or something or I think the
title was like celebrity science wait it
made a website it's on Getty Images but
you guys have to see those for college I
always wanted one of those Getty Images
okay so you have to see the photos click
on the link she's uh comedian Kelsey
cook now scroll to the bottom uh-huh oh
is that a horrible picture no that one's
not bad but you have to see oh they got
you a lot click on that what the hell
wow look at how dirty they did me that's
Midwest they took a picture just of your
shoes what's up with that that's
Midwestern mom running out to smoke a
cig and grab the mail that's those shoes
the sad like these are full picks up
kids
it's very Kate plus eight and meets
janitor wow that's really not great it's
really bad and let me see the other ones
because we've got one ankle showing yeah
that's not great these bags though where
the bags from anywhere fancy you do look
kind of famous in this
but you are there is like a uh you're
getting out of a black car a black Uber
well it's just that was the comedy club
manager that was the bus it's my mom's
car I got something for everything don't
get the plates all right Mike
my coat is from Kohl's oh man these
boots are from DSW they're so so janky
and that's funny though I went on Jim
and Sam this morning and they saw the
picture and they're like yeah but that's
just what you wore to walk in and then
like you put on like actual shoes no
that's what I wear on stage here's the
thing Jesus you look very confused here
you look like you're learning how to
walk
the way they take the pictures though
they're going to use these photos when
you murder somebody yeah because they
have like you're not like smiling or
whatever you're just you're just doing
your thing but like that one right there
that picture right there if you murder
somebody that's what they're saying
that's the photo you look a little angry
a little just like you know a little
like you're in my face yeah little
Brittany yeah Chelsea cook kills again
brought on the sticks caught in Philly
yeah so anyway that picture of the boots
made me laugh so hard and I figured you
guys that's great I kind of want that's
why I put my orange shirt on I thought I
was gonna run into some paparazzos you
got a Getty image though I mean that's
pretty sweet I always wanted one of
those yeah that's when you know you're
making it oh thanks again it's for such
silly reasons it's like just going to
work going to work for like a half sold
room or whatever it's on a Sunday night
like you guys have to be lost this is
not the person that is gonna make you
money nobody's paying 500 that's a good
price right I just saw that's the price
499 we should buy one and put it in the
studio
just a shoe one that's all right I
thought you were Jonah Hill coming in
man
it's for him a lot yeah I mean we look a
lot alike I can see it yeah that's great
yeah that's good stuff uh but what else
you said you had a few things so you
hear you had a very uh
we thought you were going to come in
prim and proper I believe right oh boy
he ended up being a real Dirtbag misread
that which we respect that's welcome to
the party baby that's what I'm saying
and then you said you left and things
have came back to you that we missed
which I'm always interested to hear now
were you hiding them at the time or you
just they just they popped back into
your psyche at some point yeah they
didn't come up and then it's one of
those things where once it's brought to
your attention how God bless you are
it's everywhere it's everywhere you have
the animals outside I believe right my
mom would feed raccoons yeah raccoon
lady yeah anybody needs the cliff notes
her mom said raccoons basically by hand
yeah
um we also I think covered that my
grandma who had started to not oh my
great-grandma had not had like all her
wits about her toriana was feeding us
like cat food right yeah sandwiches
feeding you cat food did you eat one
well I remember I like bit into one and
it was like this is
I get a little bit of that on my finger
when I'm when I'm feeding the cat I
[__] lose it it's such an icky
texture
[Laughter]
yeah
it's around you with it that canned dog
food yeah it's it's rough but dried dog
food's not that bad have you eaten it
right when I was a kid yeah sure I hate
that his mom's deodorant I did I used to
lick her roll-on deodorant I don't know
why it tasted good it was Secret
okay it was disgusting
that is so there's so many things to
unpack here yeah to me it to me it's not
just like I like the way it tastes I
think it was a bit of a you know he's a
big mama's boy yeah I was gonna say
there's like talking about I don't know
[Laughter]
I used to eat dirt too there's something
you're a little affected what do you
want he's seen a lot of [__] you gotta
wash down to deodorant
okay so so this is just like a few
random things
um have you guys ever stayed at a
DoubleTree Hotel yeah okay so you know
they've got like them the magic cookie
drawer the cookies they do the front
right in the front which is about it
with them it is it's kind of weird
double trees fancy I always thought it
was Fancy no this is it's like oh man
I'm that's like an Olive Garden thing
where like you're like a Red Lobster
where you're young and you're like oh
[__] we're going to Red Lobster and as a
kid I think if you stand a DoubleTree
you're like oh we're standing DoubleTree
brother move next to one and we used to
brag and that was like the landmark
where's Danny's new apartment right next
to the DoubleTree I thought it was like
a 4C it had a number in it I thought it
was like the Four Seasons no yeah I
didn't know I'm learning now that it's
trashy traveling salesman and divorce
they're pretty nice
well I I really don't courtyard's no
good yeah I think they're fine what
about a Hampton Inn I like a nice
Hampton Inn hmm they're pretty solid
nice okay sure yeah yeah do the
continental breakfast will you go down
there and have a little bit of powdered
eggs
I'll do like if they've got a like a
hard-boiled egg or like a banana I feel
like that's like this
that's just like a safe bath yeah I just
I've had too many weird food allergies
all that it's also very true I wouldn't
trust a hard-boiled egg unless I saw it
made I can't do it but you'll have like
powdered scrambled eggs yeah they're
pretty good but you'll like trust that
more than a hard-boiled egg I mean I
know what's good I mean using deodorant
this guy's all over the world
there's something about hard but you
don't know when they made them I know
they made those eggs that morning
or the night before but a hard-boiled
egg that could be sitting there forever
that could have been a stray it could
have sure yeah yeah we don't know that's
true
right but to date all those things
the guy who signed up Connelly just
pulls him out of his backpack pocket
they're just smushed and warm like how
great
um okay so anyway I used to stay in
DoubleTree sometimes as a kid growing up
for like foosball tournaments and stuff
sure got your family vacations and I'd
get so excited over those cookies
cookies and then I realized as an adult
that you can still go in and even if
you're not staying there you can just
ask for cookies and they'll just give
you free cookies and you'll do that
really I did do that a couple times not
in like super recent years but probably
in my 20s and I thought about that I was
like that's a pretty garbage thing to do
that you like yeah want a cookie so
badly from there that you'll just go in
like if you're near one and get a free
coach would they ask you if you're
staying here no you just walk up to the
to the thing can I have a cookie please
they probably thought you were crazy
person and just wanted to get you out of
the lobby they had people just saw my
shoes
it's local comedian Kelsey cook give her
whatever she wants to get her out of
here she's deranged comedian Kelsey cook
steals cookies
yeah from hard working
I like pictures your next picture's
gonna be a purple walk
yeah wait okay here's my thing of why I
wouldn't do I don't like doing stuff
like that I have Bannings I don't want
to get caught and then have the
embarrassment of like sir what room are
you in and then maybe like 904 and he's
like this is a six-story building and
I'm like all right I can't deal with the
rejection that that would make it I'd go
I'll go pay a hundred dollars for a
cookie even if I don't have a hundred
dollars yeah on a cookie okay to not be
shamed and embarrassed are they that
good it's usually oatmeal raisin no no
no are they chocolate chip it's a
chocolate chip it's a chocolate chip at
all for an oatmeal raisin oh my god
listen I gotta reputation I'm gonna take
my cats away from me for an oatmeal
raisin no it's a chocolate chip walnut
they're like really famous yeah
I'd rather have an oatmeal raisin to be
honest with you you know it's the best
you know oatmeal chocolate chip yeah
that is good A little cinnamon in it
I'm a chocolate Old Spice kind of guy
a little dabble do you just a touch of
athlete's foot spread that's the way I
like it uh there's not much I'll I'll do
for free
yeah uh and I think that was a big thing
my my parents grew up uh pretty poor
yeah so they were like they took it was
like a pride thing for them of like we
don't accept freestyle like we don't
accept handouts oh it's like a very like
that's not for us I might have told them
I can't remember if I was trying to be
sneaky or if I just had said hey like
I'm not staying here but I really love
your cookies like can I just get a
cookie that I would respect I think
that's I think that's what I did yeah
but I know I know I think I only did a
couple times but I um
I don't know I just thought I was kind
of a genius okay I'm a huge loser yes
I'm really down on my luck here
just looking for a hot meal I
mean okay so that's pretty I feel like
if you have to buy cookies from the
supermarket what are you buying I love
dates your Tates Tates but that's new
that's new that's new money [__] that's
they were talking about like old school
what were you rocking back in the day
like on Oreo Chips Ahoy I give it to you
yeah
yeah put that milk the chocolate chips
get real hard and the cookie gets real
mushy have you heard of this phenomenon
and I've tried it and it is you run yeah
run Oreos under the sink as we ever
talked about this what what are you what
I'm telling you it's not the milk flavor
it's the consent it it tastes just like
you've dipped it in milk I don't know if
we can ever speak again
I tried it just to try it just because
like we saw it online or something it's
a thing of people running Oreos under
the sink and it it's not so much the
milk flavor that you're tasting when you
dip it in milk except like the the
chemical change what part of Russia was
this video yeah it was one time I must
say this is crazy I'm not co-signing I'm
just saying it does it is a bit of a
female I don't know I sure don't oh my
God I don't like it cut this
find out I'm an alien
I remember when I found out that uh when
Saddam Hussein was just me and him in a
hole there's a big double stuff guy
hated Walnut chocolate chip no he used
to they said one of his favorite snacks
was he would take Doritos and he would
put water on them and he liked eating
them like that
when I heard that I was like hang that
[__] yeah I just don't
understand it makes him like spit on the
flag that's like chili killies or
something yeah can you dip Oreos in
water
stuff with a bunch of Oreo cookies and
no milk don't worry just dip them in
some water Michelle says it tastes great
and not weird
if the
hotel's picture is just Kevin in a wig
they're like okay I got the same art she
just like it's going to all these
lengths to not be an alien and Michelle
does Michelle have Kevin's eyes this
does feel like you're trying to control
the narrative yeah and it's not weird it
says I'm Russia
image guy with an Oreo in the sink
you hired a focus group oh my God I'm
telling you I'm just saying
oh that's pretty classy use a fork I've
used to fall through the you put a fork
in oh sorry
you can get the whole thing yeah right
here Oreos soaked in water
yeah I'm telling you man whatever try it
out there report back in the comments
the articles on porousguy.com
loser.net says it's cool
I'm not co-signed for the record I'm
dying I've seen it and I experimented
about to walk out of here
Toby start our own podcast
[Laughter]
oh man okay what was yeah do you have
another one I had a couple other ones so
I love it I I didn't try a tamale until
two years ago and I didn't know that you
aren't supposed to eat the corn husk
Jesus I Gotta Give it I've never had one
because I was always unsure if you're
supposed to eat them or not thank you
yeah no I'm right there with you so I
almost broke a tooth they are very tough
to try to get through it's overdone I
was it's like eating a football I yeah I
was over the sink just like put some
water on it I've been eating shrimp
tails her whole life
I didn't know what to do with them
that's crazy shout out to a tamale and
you just mentioned what was the thing
that you mentioned the Soggy Doritos oh
chili killies which we had for the first
time uh one of my favorites it's such a
good it's when the tortilla chip is like
soggy and they put it inside stuff we
had it at the place in La that we walked
to and had breakfast it is phenomenal
it's they're like cooked in um in sauce
and so they get a little second and they
put eggs on it and right yeah okay yeah
yeah
big fan I just feel like in my defense
like tacos burritos there's a you know a
tortilla situation so I thought that I
thought that was just something it's the
same are you by yourself or you were you
with other people by myself sure
no I couldn't even get through it and I
was just like what the hell's back eat
the hell is wrong with these goddamn
tamales
got bark on it
I had a Google like an idiot like the
whitest person on the planet Google how
do you eat how do you eat a tomato how
do you eat Mexican food that feels so
strange picture of me it's just like a
diaper then you just open it and eat the
inside yeah they're pretty what's on the
inside I've never opened one up really
it's just kind of like the inside of a
burrito it's okay so I figured there was
another wrapping in there no see I don't
really get it what it's like cornmeal
it's like soft cornmeal and meat mixed
together it's like opening up a burrito
no it's the the it's cornmeal
um I'm saying there's nothing you open
it up to the thing that you eat yes with
a fork that's what I'm saying that's
what I'm saying okay you open it up it's
like picture like polenta it's like it's
like a thicker version you're getting
caught up on the contents of the burrito
while I'm getting caught on the
structure like you open it up and then
the food you eat is in there yeah yes
yeah you like to eat it with a fork yeah
he's like no it's polenta yeah I
understand it's not a burrito
okay uh I'll give you that I'm weird on
food I don't understand a lot of food I
was a very picky eater for a long time
and there's just certain things that
I've missed forever that I go I don't
mess with that stamps.com baldy
stamps.com
yeah we want to Edge out the competition
gang get yourself over to the stamps.com
you do your mailing from your office or
your home sure or your home office yeah
or to bedroom send your chain letters
that's what I did
uh you're mailing from the can
stamps.com lets you print your own
Postage and shipping labels right from
your home or office it's ready to go in
minutes guys I've been saying it for
years I am not only uh a pitch we set
all the cards out I've been I've been
I've been a customer for years way
before they were a sponsor it's
fantastic to send you a little scale a
little Bebop boom you throw it on you
feel like you're working in a delivery
Center or something it's great really
Jeff Bezos wait this whole system going
we did it's great it's a good time I
have fun it's a bonding experience with
me my best pal yeah uh you print postage
whenever you do business all you need is
a computer and a printerstamps.com even
send you a free scale so you get
everything you need to get started set
up your business for Success when you
get started with stamps.com today sign
up with promo code garbage for a special
offer that includes a four-week trial
free postage look at that and a free
digital scale there you go no long-term
commitments or contracts just go to
stamps.com Click the microphone at the
top on a page enter the code garbage do
it can't be let's talk about that liquid
IV baby Machi hats on this am to kick a
hangover like mother's milk I was all
jammed up a few weeks ago as you folks
know 103 temperature uh-huh it's going
out both ends it was brutal yeah the
only thing that got me through was
Liquid IV and some old episodes of
Seinfeld ain't no ruin it shout out to
liquid IV I like the uzi pineapple or
uzo pineapple Yakuza pineapple not good
with names
it's the easiest way to stay hydrated it
gives you five essential vitamins and
hydrates two times faster than water
alone just with one stick of liquid IV I
got the whole family on it I take it
down them they sent the good Folks at
liquid IV send us
it's fantastic it's free from gluten
dairy and soy liquid IV contains three
times the electrolytes of traditional
sports drinks look at that and you can
grab your liquid IV in bulk nationwide
at Costco or you can get 20. you can get
20 off when you go to liquid iv.com use
our code garbage at check or get Costco
yes Costco's got enough goddamn case all
right go to uh I don't care how good the
hot dogs are help the boys out liquid
iv.com use code garbage that's 20 off
anything you order when you shop for
better hydration today using promo code
garbage at liquid iv.com do it can you
use chopsticks
that's how you were eating the tamale
yeah what kind of place is this
sometimes when I'm on I'm on and I'm
like you know what I mean if I have like
two beers in me and I'm not thinking
about I'm in a flow state I'm just
grabbing it I'll grab a fly if I need to
I've got certain nights man I'm all
thumbs I've gotten so much better with
them I'm like Miyagi with those things I
could grab a wasp wow Kevin's like uh
same with bowling and Chopsticks that's
how I am we're like some nights on
bowling I'm a [__] Dynamics
it's just gutters and that's the same
with chopsticks with me it's like some
days I got this down yeah it's just off
yes gotta be absence of mind you can't
be thinking about it you just gotta be
[__] you know in there yeah like a
quarterback in the Super Bowl baby just
execute yeah you do maybe need like a
little buzz like a little alcohol yeah
to get out of here yeah get out of your
head yeah but when you really if
somebody just was like teach me how I'd
be like duh I don't even think I'm doing
it right I do it in a version that works
I'll say this I'm better I've seen you
operate a fork it's not much better I
don't know I'm bad I'm not good I'm
better with the wooden one I'm not good
with anything I'm better with the wooden
ones the metal ones forget about it oh
yeah I feel like I'm doing surgery yeah
you ever catch the metal why are you
looking at me like that no I don't know
what do you mean uh no I've never used
metal chop I don't think I don't know
where you think I'm eating and I'm
getting metal chopsticks
the Korean barbecue is probably gonna do
is metal Chopsticks I asked for a fork
this is America
do you really no if someone else does
maybe I'll dial you know I'm not gonna
be the first guy to give me a four yeah
if there's a child at the table I'll say
it's for him I feel like if you order a
cheeseburger at a Chinese restaurant or
a Mexican restaurant that's pretty
garbage sure but they do them good at
the Mexican spots really oh man yeah uh
yeah yeah yeah a little bit of jalapeno
some cheddar cheese
kind of they're it's like adopted as
their oh okay okay yeah okay fantastic
um the Chinese spots in Philly uh shout
out to Temple star they're chicken
fingers and fries unbelievable it's like
a dollar fifty it's crazy I lived on
them the whole time I was in college
it's like it sounds so good they're so
good yeah I've mentioned this too this
is an underrated thing I don't know if
it might only be in New York but the
Chinese spots here
they make homemade iced tea and homemade
lemonade [__] lights out poke a hole
in my dog
they come in the big courts yeah yeah
what else you got okay this is my last
thing
um I I think you guys have asked people
before about if they have ever owned
exotic animals sure so I grew up with a
chinchilla
for like oh you fat Joe
what what is a chinchilla I didn't know
you had Middle East oil money yeah holy
[__] we got one at a pet store in
Spokane when I was eight her name was
Josie oh they're kind of cute she's so
cute they're kind of cute I mean they're
not hideous they're like a fluffy
squirrel it's like a weird rabbit it's
like a weird yes yeah like a squirrel
rabbit rabbit grow up next to a power
plant with those goddamn ears
um but they live for like
teen years
crazy long lifespan so she lived for a
long time but
for a while uh we would let her just run
around a room like there was like an
extra bedroom and we could just kind of
let her run around this makes me sound
like is there Furniture in that room
um so there was like a bookshelf okay
and it read it
like chinchilla is very well read we
realized that um they chew on wood and
so we came home one day and looked and
she had like chewed through the Bible
and we were like well we're all going
we're all going goddamn devil brought
the goddamn devil in this household
yeah but she like ate through a bookcase
it was it was pretty crazy so yeah but I
just feel um are they expensive
chinchillas I mean the Spokane pet store
I don't think yeah they're probably not
probably yeah I know they're Furs a
chinchilla chinchilla fur they are 15
grand I'm looking at one right now oh
yeah the code no for the yeah to get one
as a pet it was probably next to nothing
there's probably a lot of chinchillas
you got to use yeah cause they're little
guys I know it's a shame man it's really
sad they're such sweet creatures but
yeah I feel like that was a very um
sweet goddamn Bible the holy book
everybody pulled out a scarf right now
yeah
what was the name Josie Josie all right
that was her name at the pet store and
we just kept it was that her primary
spot was in that room would you just
literally just did you have a cage for
it we had a cage for her but I mean we I
think she lived through like two
different moves and so one house she had
something chinchilla yes but they uh
they can't get their fur wet so they
take dust baths so we would keep uh shoe
boxes and you pour this special dust in
a shoe box and you stick it in their
cage and they go and they roll around in
it in a bunch of times why can't they
get their their fur wet I think it makes
them sick
I just got my her dude some sort of
temperature regulation maybe I don't
know really but yeah anyway it just it
all feels very like Joe Exotic it's it's
a little garbagey yeah no it is anything
that these they're cute I'll give you
that but I mean if you got animals that
are eating the Bible and doing dust
baths oh I know that's not classy well
my mom is feeding raccoon it's like
that's not a great combo oh that's great
um I love getting the tables turned on
us a little bit all trash 100 yeah
uh down the line yeah that ain't good
the cookies is kind of sweet I get it
thank you I get to cook no you go buy it
cook the tamales I mean that's just I'm
with you on the tamales it didn't come
with a set of instructions how are you
supposed to yeah
you know how to eat pizza don't you yes
I'm a goddamn America
it's Italian
oh
this guy's breaking my balls
all right let's do some cues we're gonna
do some cues on the patreon with Kelsey
here again new special out over on our
website check it out it's going to be
available on YouTube March 9th one of
the best out there on tour go see her we
love her you love her
[Laughter]
oh man
it is weird sitting next to you with
that shirt on I've worn it next to you
before you guys look fantastic it's so
great for camera I feel like these
colors together were like a really nice
house
chinchillas yeah we do yeah this is the
most colorful we've ever been yeah I
just picked these up we look like a boy
band in the 90s where it's like very
coloring everybody yeah a little yeah a
little pop of everything I like it uh
all right let's get into it over there
when you sign up for patreon we will
answer your garbage question on the air
uh it's just the best way to do it all
right this one's from Jason 10 homie
never had one red did you ever have your
addresses spray painted on your trash
cans
for sure no
I forgot where you grew up was it more
rural or suburb like what was the um so
Spokane for the first like eight years
and then Cheney which is kind of in the
boonies it's like in the wheat field I
remember that yeah yeah yeah yeah so no
one's I mean no one's running up and
stealing your trash cans no but I always
lived in neighborhoods like it was very
I don't know just typical yeah very
residential we always had the house
number spray painted on there so nobody
got cute we had them in Sharpie just
yeah same thing just in case okay uh I
don't think I had that now why most
people now
the trash place the trash people
the trash people
that's true the Sanitation Company yeah
is that what it is the trash yeah yeah
trash truck yeah shouldn't we know this
yes we look like fakes I think there's a
gas leak in here
um Teddy's taking us down
yes my day my mom just got a new one and
it's the size of a [__] telephone
booth they're huge yeah the trucks hook
them up now and dump them in so like
they don't have to do them by hand
anymore oh wow yeah I've seen those
um it's uh they're huge but yeah we had
I remember I remember writing in Sharpie
real bad and it's like who's gonna steal
though you'd see them they would though
they'd steal them back in the day in the
80s and 90s they take them the kids
would take them but for why I don't know
what they do with them yeah but I mean
they're making gravity bongs or
something yeah I don't know keep their
chinchillas in there
can't chew through them
um we also never had Lids Lids lasted
for maybe a week sure and then the lids
were gone a storm would hit or something
we'd use garbage can Lids to sled yeah
that was big yeah the metal ones are
plastic both metal if you wanted to
really cook yeah I wanted to really get
the cruising altitude you take the
handle off right yeah yeah it just goes
well I used to take the handle and put
on the other side and pretend like I was
Captain America
there's a couple weeks ago
all right just on some Liu Kang five
dollar dirt back here how trash is it to
drive to a nicer neighborhood to use the
24-hour fitness center there I respect
that I respect that too
yeah you gotta yeah you know you gotta
be good you gotta fake it to make it you
know what I mean play the part how do
you get in there though if you belong to
it so he drives past the one in his
shitty neighborhood yeah and goes to the
it's like going trick-or-treating in a
rich neighborhood oh I got it instead of
using the Planet Fitness in his town he
uses a town over yeah I thought it was
the hoity toys I thought it was a
community that had like a free Fitness
Center
no
that's what I thought uh no I respect
the grocery store yeah one of the nicer
gym first nicer pizza place whatever it
is yeah we had um so my neighborhood
where I grew up our neighborhood was
built I think in like the 50s and then
in the 70s or 80s
a newer part of the neighborhood was
built and they were nicer homes yeah so
when you come down my when you come to
the street that I live off of if we had
company or we were like bringing
somebody to the house for the first time
we'd take them the nice way show off the
gun show off the new name for sure I
wouldn't do that because then in
comparison your place looks shitty it
always backfired yeah you should take
them through like the apartment
on my bed you show them the wrong side
of the tracks I remember bringing a girl
home or something like that when we went
to the neighbor she's like oh these
houses are not what the [__] yeah do me
a favor those blindfold them yeah why is
it dark out all of a sudden it was a
beautiful sunny day oh it's raining over
your house you're shooting out the
street lights on your block
God damn city oh my God yeah I respect
that move too yeah hustle you gotta [__]
it it's also like yeah why not if you're
paying for it well there's also such a
psychology energy with working out like
if you're going to a place that looks
like [__] that you feel like [__] being
in yeah sure you're not gonna be as
likely I think to want to get motivated
to do it it's also a very good point
pretty good just start going to a gym in
Beverly Hills
laughs
be over at the White House working out
try to get this guy motivated baby yeah
people talk about that with workout
clothes like if you wear clothes that
fit you well that are like a little
higher quality you feel more real you
know I just did that yes I got a Peloton
to try to try to lose some pounds and
there's a suit
I feel like a gentleman dry cleaning
bills are through the roof
but yeah but it's the same thing and I
bought just because I was just working
out uh in like basketball shorts and
whatever and I went out and just not
even expensive just like actual workouts
what are you wearing Lululemon no I just
got it off Amazon tights
Amazon has some good looking lemon dupes
I will say over like a third of the
price my little hoodie is uh one of
those is a Lululemon dupe nice which is
also trash dupe is a fire term I've
never heard that that's great really
really for duplicate that's great for
knockoff I love it oh wow I didn't coin
it that's it's definitely it's out there
yeah I don't think so Toby
yeah you do you do feel better yeah I
feel like an athlete I feel like I look
like an athlete I should say it's
backward because I think a lot of
Gatorade squirt bottle yeah I do have a
belt on squirt bottle it came with the
system
I'd be stupid not to use it when we were
kids we were just on like a Saturday my
parents we would just drive around to
like nicer neighborhoods and just drive
the joints around and just look at the
nice houses yeah and feel wealthy for a
little while yeah yeah take a chase out
of the neighborhood okay let's talk
about that true classic oh wait talk
about an instant classic yeah they got
the boxer briefs now they got it all man
I can squeeze into them they're comfy
calling your sexy underwear walking
around the house go get the mail I wear
to tease in the house and the bird likes
to sleep in them very top quality very
comfortable soft too but not that
software it shows all the the nooks and
crannies on your body it's soft to touch
but still sturdy enough to keep you keep
you looking like a unit it's good stuff
I can't squeeze into them yet but that's
my goal to be able to wear true Classics
sure start flexing on people yeah show
the pipes they got everything polos to
work out clothes as the big man said
boxer brief true classic has everything
to upgrade your look uh premium clothing
without the premium price they have long
options for the tall guys up to Triple
XL baby there you go uh get comfortable
get get comfortable and get going and
upgrade your wardrobe with true Classics
I got one right now check it look at you
I get 25 off at trueclassics.com with
code garbage free shipping included on
purchases over one hundred dollars
that's 25 off at trueclassic.com garbage
100 risk-free guarantee 30-day return
policy you can't go wrong I've been a
customer since before they were uh an
Advertiser I've been for years I've been
buying them they're fantastic you're
like getting laid grab some true
Classics it's look good feel good season
get on board now back to that gosh darn
show back to the show yeah you think
with working out that you should wear
like your nastiest gross yeah just like
clothes with holes in them because
you're like well then it gets sweaty and
gross but then you feel like [__] when
you put it on it's like low self-worth
clothing yeah yeah you have expensive
clothes or do you have any expensive
pieces jackets anything shoes that the
jacket was from Kohl's I mean I've seen
your Getty Images
no I really do I'm not great at like
what about the bag in the in the in the
picture nice it was a nice green bag oh
that was like a hundred that's like but
again like people do designer purse for
like five grand I I don't I could never
do that you know what I did spend and
um I love it money on I got a litter
robot it's a um a robot litter box
you're gonna say like a [__] Porsche
or something
you got a Roomba congratulations
it's a self-scooping litter box and
they're [__] they're so expensive
what did that set you back
600 bucks
you are free cookies
600. you're making cash
are you flying in front are you thinking
that 600 is is cheap that's yeah he's
also very bad with mouse so you gotta
gauge it you seem very fiscally
responsible conservative level-headed I
get creators right now I've seen him
take a loan to go on vacation okay
he called it a small business one stop
it's not that long ago oh my God this
show was successful it was last year I
still owe seven G's on it
I'm thinking the minimum payments yeah
so yeah sorry if he stuck his nose up at
your 600 kitty litter oh my God I feel
like when I came on the first time I
shared my credit score and uh my credit
card limit you guys were like whoa
that's like the craziest what was it I
think my credit score is like eight
that's really yeah I'm like 720 now okay
but that was we started the show it was
5 35. okay well that's great and your
credit limit was what
um it's up there right it's up there 30.
I think it's 25. damn but but yeah I
mean to me 600 for a litter box that's
like a lot of money sure no it is you're
not you're not wrong okay you just said
they're foleyville for the first time oh
okay okay welcome to town his house is
in the bad part we're back
I'm gonna drive you through the nice
houses the way you set it up I thought
it was gonna be like a couple of G's or
something like that no I just think it
for what it is like a regular litter box
is like 20 but self-scooping that's so
nice you only have to change the tryout
like once a week because it just Scoops
it and puts it in a little little shelf
yeah it's I hate scooping Leonard how
many cats you got two huh and just moved
in with my boyfriend he's got a golden
doodle so you know it's just a
just a circus where are you based out of
now uh I just moved to Minneapolis
I love it good for the road you can be
bop and Sky you're in the middle it's
perfect and he's a touring comic too so
it's weird like once you realize that
you're on the road more often than
you're not you're like oh where are you
lit like the airport situation is so
crucial shout out to Queens LaGuardia
Airport three feet away from us that's
huge we're flying it out of LaGuardia
right d-bones
yes sir clean living baby yeah
Minneapolis is so Central like flights
are pretty short time zone changes
aren't crazy that's why I never
understood flying back from the west
coast to go work the road and so you got
to leave a day early and when you leave
you're like I got the early flight of a
tenure like I land in New York at 8 55
p.m yeah that [__] sucks I was losing
I mean by the end of the year I was on
the road for like an extra month if you
just totaled up how many weekends I
would have to fly in a day early
it's not you flying up front what are
you doing
um so I'm Delta and I get the uh you
guys Delta too yeah yeah You Gotta Be
You gotta be up there what are you
Diamond
um I was right about to hit Diamond
before the end of the year I was pla I'm
Platinum whoa it's pretty good though
thanks what are you guys I'm gold okay
I'm silver I think okay but you'll get
it I would [__] jamming me up
I'm just happy to be there
boys aluminum foil
wrapper back here he's trying to sit in
first class okay which one of you guys
has eight Sky miles
borrow miles to go on a vacation you've
explained this to me but what so you
that all goes away they're like sick
days right you can't roll them over it's
for the the previous year what you
earned in 2023 establishes your status
for 2024. but you're still as close to
Diamond as you were last year just it
won't go into effect until next year or
do you start back at zero
I have to literally screw you do kind of
screw you let me ask you this you guys
need to play you guys have the um that
Amex yeah yeah okay so all of your
things are getting you Delta miles and
helping your status kinda my limit's
only a thousand bucks so I can't use it
on a lot of stuff oh James me up okay so
the one for the business yeah can't work
for both of us oh okay that Reserve is a
nice one we had we each have our
personal I just got the Iota MX I think
800 bucks for about 12 years
really Jam me up and they wouldn't then
give me a personal card because I owed
the money for so long I think they
finally settled for like 180 bucks or
something that I paid off not too long
ago okay uh look at you talking them
down I know uh well they were happy to
get rid of me and then I try to keep
getting one they want to give me one and
I finally got approved and they gave me
like I went through Delta because they
have their approval process is way more
lenient right actual yeah they're loose
and I got like a 35 000 credit limit I
did lie about how much money I made I
did say I make seven million dollars a
year oh my God I don't really need this
credit card I'm doing you guys a favor
okay listen you guys want me as a client
I'm telling you hey you want someone to
step you at the end of the moment
I'm your guy all right that's good you
use the lounge at the airport yes and
that's a new thing that's the litter
robot and using the lounge all right
yes
shutting my coal skin moving on up uh
yeah man the Delta Lounge what a
difference that makes so I got the
reserve AMEX card and that gets you into
the Delta lounges
um yeah it's crazy how just having like
even 30 minutes of time uh before the
flight where you're not in a place where
kids are screaming with the animals
we like to be you'll like the
exclusivity of it just as you go out
there's somewhere a little choir a
little different that not everybody can
get to I want to be in there you're
taking a granola bar or two from there
you throw it throw it in your pocket yep
yep take some fruit
um I know
[Laughter]
she's in there with an Ikea bag filling
it up the big blue double I can't
really get a pound of turkey yeah
salami sliced in I will say I wish they
didn't switch
um breakfast to lunch so early because
sometimes it's like that's an epidemic
around the country you show up somewhere
like 10 15 they're like breakfast is
done breakfast all day here's your home
all day minimum 11 minimum minimum yeah
it's like I so but I'll be hungry and so
I'm eating like barbecue chicken and
[__] like yeah
10 15 and my stomach's all weird for the
day I don't know that breakfast is the
best
like free buffet style thing that should
just be all the time Delta's got a good
breakfast they do they're already flying
out of here oh LaGuardia ah there's a
there's a great AMX and JFK amazing
okay okay I just used it for the first
time wow
I paid my bill goddamn that's a
different Kevin Ryan
come on
uh all right this is in the same vein uh
this one's from John 10 Boston homie is
it garbage if you have to Google can I
pay One credit card bill with another
credit card oh my God which can you I
think he used to be able to uh I don't
know they Jam you up with stuff like
that you can I got a buddy who's upside
down in about three different cards dude
yeah
no it's like a game of three card Monty
yeah shout out to yams in Chicago you
can pay your Capital One bill with your
Amex I think so man just chasing tails
because I feel like when it asks to for
you to add your payment method I feel
like it's always a banking yeah it's got
to be your the routing number yeah
suppose you have a high interest balance
on one or multiple credit cards you're
looking for to consider Consolidated
over APR you can you pay off credit card
in short yes you can pay a credit card
off with another credit card there's
more than one way to do you can't pay
rent with a credit card found that out
the hard way I can't now I guess my yeah
mine is my Batman's on my bank yeah yeah
okay huh are you guys paying your credit
card off every month
I just uh yeah I try not to put anything
on it I was so bad with money up until
like a year ago yeah because I never had
any uh so I try not to put anything on
them really like just smaller purchases
and then I'll just use my debit card I
don't even know what you mean exactly
I'll be honest with you I mean is it
zero you are a new financial advisor by
the way you mean at the end of the month
it's completely paid off right you made
the payment every month should be
completely paid off so that way you're
not accruing any interest because we're
not doing that
what so I everything I put on my credit
cards I don't put anything on your debit
card well then you just clear it okay
and then clear it all at the end of the
month because when you put everything on
your credit cards you're getting all of
those points you're making money for
yourself with whatever you know business
partner thing that you're with so Delta
Miles all that
but you pay it off every month so that
they can't charge you any interest
damn you might be the smartest person I
ever met
that's pretty good
yeah I keep cleaning up on points so
it's points and Sky miles Platinum dude
yeah man you hit us you just hit a
certain number or a certain spend you
get x amount of points is it all AMX is
that where you use this for everything I
have one card I have a personal Amex and
then a business Amex so both of those
funnel to the delta I'm telling you it's
like the quickest way you can get better
status and you'll get your seats
upgraded all the time and it's it's all
the same money whether you're spending
it on your debit card or putting on your
credit card and then paying it off it's
all coming from the same place I always
forget
okay set it up on autopay
no I mean I always forget to use that
AMEX card yeah use it yeah
I got a Capital One they don't do
[__] [__] yeah I don't except bust my
balls I did Capital One for a long time
and then it's you realize it's not so
that's interest charges at the end of
the month I mean dude you're 50 years I
always wondered what that was I thought
that was like my dude I didn't spend 220
at interest
you think it's a bar
[__] been there babe I swear
charge anyway
[Laughter]
oh my god you're an all-time dummy
sometimes if I see a charge up there
that I don't know then like you can look
it up and it tells you where like the
corporate headquarters is right and it's
like I ain't never even [__] been to
Wisconsin
[__] oh my God because I see that
I've never been to a Target in Wisconsin
I see that on Uber when I put it on my
credit card because Uber is based in San
Francisco I'm like some son of a [__]
in San Fran this guy's got my credit
laughs
I will say though I couldn't do the
whole pain the credit card thing off
every month until
I don't know a few years ago but before
then I was just like putting things on
credit cards with money I didn't have
and you know that's what really jams you
up but they're spending like hey I'm
gonna go on vacation and I don't have it
yeah if you're just spending within your
means and putting your D your monthly
weekly purchases on it that you had that
you were gonna spend anyway right and
then just paying it all off it's like if
you spend two thousand dollars a month
on your credit card that you would have
just spent on your debit card you can
just put in your debit card and then
have it on auto my appearance that's how
I roll yes yes my parents said that that
three-card Monty with the credit cards
my whole life yeah I remember my mom
breaking out shoe boxes to do build to
balance the checkbook and like there
would be I just remember like there's
gonna be a fight and I'm gonna be
grounded because she's gonna be upset
about at the money in her bank again
yeah I spent a lot of time as a kid in
Money Tree lobbies with my with my mom
like yeah do you have some money tree
out here uh it's like a loan place yeah
yeah yeah so I saw that like I saw how
dangerous credit cards can be and that
they're not just free money and so I
think my brother and I both have tried
really really hard to not yeah yeah I've
got that route our friend Matt patches
of air I don't want a very funny bit uh
I mean I just thought you yelled at the
bank
like I just thought you yelled at the
teller every time because you grew up
and my mom was just always yelling at
the teller
so y'all you had to yell at that I want
to deposit my check please
shout out to Maddie yeah uh also I mean
this is a very uh this is another one
this is from Cartman I haven't had a
question Rhett
I'm sorry current debate in my house is
what's the trashiest airline wife says
spirit I say Southwest because you as an
airline you get to see the sign can't be
worse than when you line up
like it's a city bus there's most most
of the fights and videos and all that
[__] is Southwest oh I think I was gonna
say Spirit or forever yeah Spirit or
Frontier but Southwest they're mostly
Spirit Southwest is where they try to do
like uh like dinner acts right don't
aren't they like doing bits
they're like the hey every they tell
jokes yeah yeah when they're doing the
pre-flight announcements yeah Spirit
does yeah yeah it's real yeah
oh yeah yeah Southwest is definitely a
lot of like Open Mic Vibe yeah yeah like
trying to do bits or voices or whatever
zip it and get me a bloody mary
give me my seatbelt extender
oh my God that's so funny the only thing
I was missing from that was toots
you know my Bloody Mary there was a 98
chance he was gonna say toots after that
to be honest with you
uh yeah I I have flown Frontier a good
amount out of Trenton for some [__]
stupid reason Frontier names the planes
they have the animal it's like the
Rainforest Cafe of Airlines there's like
exotic animals for reasons on the plane
I don't like that they have the name on
the on the plane yeah the animal there's
like a fox and he's like this is Willie
the fox yeah that's real [__] asking
permission to land Willie the fox please
that's real uh World War II bomber to me
sure yeah they're Hobbies shot down and
Trenton only has two has only has two
gates and I remember we were delayed
wait that's their Hub is trying that's
what they they're the only plane there I
think and they were I remember the guy
being like we're next in line for the
like we [__] should be there's only
two goddamn Gates who's in front of us
we're next in line for departure the
[__] are you talking about
yeah I try not to fly any of them
because I don't this is Gary than cougar
takes off we'll be on our way I try not
to fly any of those Airlines uh because
I don't want to get beat up and end up
on the Internet is specifically sure
yeah because people just get because the
problem is uh it was explained to me
is those smaller Airlines they get
delayed they don't get the gates because
like Delta goes [__] I have
three planes sitting here give us Gates
and Delta yeah sure your Delta oh so
yeah that's that they get pushed back
all the frontier the spirits so
everything gets delayed so then your
flight's been delayed this has been
delayed that's been delayed and you've
been at the airport for seven hours your
kids are screaming and people just start
swinging even without that and not that
I've traveled a lot like I didn't travel
before we started touring I didn't
travel I think the last time I was on a
plane was like five years ago and I'd
only been on a plane maybe four times in
my life yeah but in that in the little
amount of time we've been traveling it's
just a heated situation for some reason
dude everybody's a [__] dick yeah
about everything yeah even if there is
no delay they're a dick to the counter
person the counter person is a dick when
you're getting on when you're getting on
the plane everybody's a dick when you're
getting all it's just there's just it's
a pressure cooker yeah it really is yeah
if I get why people lose it man I mean I
I got angry like I I get tense of the
world like like if he bumps into me one
more time I'm gonna fight you know it's
like yeah that [__] you just get really
tempted oh we'll ask you this how do you
feel about putting a seat back
that's a great question because I feel
like this has been talked about a lot
lately and I didn't even think that
there was a debate about it but I I
always put my seat back whoa and some
people think that that's apparently like
rude
but I'm like why wouldn't we all just
put our seat back and fly more
comfortably
give them the heads up or you just drop
it back just
really even like I thought everybody did
and then I've there I feel like I've
seen other podcast Clips or whatever I
don't know if it was on this one but I
think KFC and fidelberg were talking
about oh okay yeah okay
I I don't okay so how do you guys feel
about it first ice it's either I no
longer like you hey I accepted you for
eating deodorant you [__] I was a little
kid
that's why I had a way to put the seat
back I'm back there eating my deodorant
like let me eat breakfast everyone in
his third lunch that day uh you don't
check to see if they have the tray down
or something well I do it like right as
we like as you are up there so nobody's
got like drinks or anything yet I also
don't slam it back I'm not trying to
like break somebody's nose I just gently
it's like a three inch it's it's nothing
but it's it's more comfortable for the
person flying and we all should do it I
feel like people that don't like it are
like you're in my face like well then
you lean back you make yourself working
yeah but then you're the dick to the
person your make this is the this is my
take on it I agree it should it should
be an all or nothing thing and it's not
your fault it's on there you know what I
mean like they do make the seats that go
back there is that there is that
argument for it my thing is yes they
shouldn't you're making now me ruin
someone else's trip
I can't watch the TV when it comes all
the way back but don't you want to lean
back
not really why not I don't know have you
a little bit yeah I don't
I don't I'll even eat it if someone
leans back I Won't Go Back
don't understand this is so fascinating
to me sure but aren't you more
comfortable on a plane I think when
we're on a plane we're all just trying
to be the most comfortable we can within
reason so if your seat
you're impeding on someone else's
comment if so if the guy behind me I'll
go back you gotta give a heads up I
think
no you need a heads up
yeah you just want people to be like hey
there big Feller I'm gonna bring her in
a little bit
you'll take out my esophagus
I almost got into a thing with some old
guy on a flight he [__] slammed it
back on me wow I put the kibosh on it
real quick you act like he called you a
[__] while he did it he just was trying
to get the button to work and then it
finally worked and you were also drunk
yeah my boyfriend just talked about this
that he leaned his back and the guy
started like kneeing the back of his
seat really aggressively and he was like
are you all right he's like be better if
you didn't put your seat back and but
he's like but that that's how I feel
like but you are allowed to and I feel
like everybody I do understand that
argument I don't think it's right I
think there should be a thing they
should like the Bell should go and it
goes everybody put your seat back yeah
everybody get comfortable okay just
explain to me why you don't like to lean
back
uh unless because I know this is the way
I feel it sucks when someone comes back
so you're doing it out of courtesy yes
out of courtesy for the person I feel
like I'm in a barber's chair
when I lean back but like how like if
you've got like a five hour flight you
want to sit like this for five hours
when you could sit like this
this is so if I I mean if we're being
honest if we have a five hour flight I'm
up front and probably hopefully I'll lay
flat if we're going across country
Hammer drunk waste
full-blown drunk I'm sleeping by the
time we get to like Minneapolis I'm out
yeah let's see I could be laying in the
aisle what about like a three-hour
flight
uh uh it's a three-hour flight you're in
like Comfort plus you're in college I'm
sitting up straight in the buzz
wow this is so interesting also we fly
in the front of the plane now okay uh
okay
irresponsibly financially every time man
with money
I love it I love it interest charges Yes
Loans to go on vacation
I'm interested in looking like a big
[__] yeah want to feel cool for 52
minutes to get to Cleveland goddammit
to spend 80 grand Shore oh my God I'm
bad with money
[Applause]
okay and MX anyway if I'm out in front
of the comedy club and uh I'm getting an
Uber if there's other Comics out front
I'll get an Uber black just to look cool
oh my God it's also I think that's I
think it's a size thing at this point
sure a little bit it's nice he tried to
lie to me last night he's like oh look
we were both getting Ubers out of here
oh look they sent a truck look they sent
me a huge Escalade I'm like
he goes That's for the same price I go
that was like he was going like eight
blocks I'm like they're charging you 48
dollars idiot I was on who breeds oh my
God yeah uh we're bad with a butt back
to the
um
yeah I'll probably I just eat I just did
I flew back from Puerto Rico the other
day and the guy in front of me went back
and I just ate it
okay yeah man it's such a fascinating uh
debate that I didn't even realize
existed until recently I I I I I've
always been I don't do it I've been on
the thing of it should be in All In All
or nothing and the guy in the front
shouldn't need to go back
what do you mean what do you mean he's
got enough no one's coming back into him
no one's like
but that but yeah he goes back it's not
about feet though it's I know yeah it's
the spine stuff you do a neck pillow
I just don't like to carry it around I
would like to have one with me but then
it's like you're like going to the
bathroom it's like brushing up against
the toilet seat and [__] I've never seen
people walking around the airport with
them just on I know it's like dude
that's that's rough yeah that feels good
it's like we're in a football helmet
when you're not at a game yeah
I think the reason it's become such a
debate is that they've jammed more
people on the plane sure
it used to be classy yeah you're like 15
feet away from everybody yeah but
tickets also used to be like it was like
only reserved for that was like a luxury
now it's anybody can fly on spear for 49
bucks yeah yeah get tased put the seat
back oh man if I get beat up on a plane
that's the last thing dude waiting at a
terminal or whatever oh it never goes
down the way you think you think you're
gonna you think it's gonna it gets messy
oh yeah everybody starts no one's really
traveling alone you're trying you got a
brother a cousin something sure yeah the
girl star fight it's a whole thing yeah
I'm out
[__] I mean I'm on every week and
I'm gonna feel like such a dick if I
lean my secret
that feels weird you have to
hey there little guy yes so aggressive
completely turn around
smash your face okay
coming back coming back up
we gotta wrap it up though gang
congratulations on the new special The
Hustler as we said you can get over
there to website kelseycook.com yes also
going to be available March 9th yep
March 9th over there on a used tube
touring all over the place thank you so
much for coming I think that's what
folks don't know
um kelseycook.com for tour dates and the
special uh Kelsey cook comedy on
Instagram and Tick Tock and
self-helpless podcast if you want my
podcast great absolutely fantastic what
do you got for him guys we're all over
the road uh shows are selling out if you
don't snooze on the tickets get them
we're not gonna be adding shows
everywhere but we are even adding second
shows Tampa Austin uh get those tickets
link is in the description come see us
gang we love you and we'll see you next
week